That kind of company, isn't it?
That manga and illustration that came from Japan is
not a customer.  That
's why Mr. Oshii sent Mr. Wear, whose time difference was regrettable,
and one day, I had
a project for a movie,
so I asked if I could have him design the characters.
That's part of my calligraphy work, not the main part of my work
.
It's just that, so it's
not about what I wanted to be when I got that customer.Then, of
course, all that work starts with that
kind of input.
Regardless of the
etiquette, all the work from the other groups, such as illustrations, will be accepted from the other group
, and the work will start in the form of me receiving it.
The moving individual is something like
that, so that manga is at my roots,
and drawing pictures of the work
that happens in that manga, no needles.  I'm not good at it, but at
the root of everything there
is a profession called manga, and for me, the river is
the whole expression of my son
, or the emotions of the character I created.
I really like the Prime Minister's work of directing the worldview that surrounds Sakata and spinning it into a single story,
so after all there is a manga and my activities have a different color.
There's
Miyaki, and I can't even count the number of nets I can count
San Frances, and I
've had 4 webs, 5 times, but I don't have
to say anything about being an intern
.
Well, this time, Kinokuniya's
three committees are budget committee members at this Peru Fes.  I came 8km down from the meeting,
which also serves as a PR for
my new product, so
um, except for doing that here, it's basically like going back to that room and
doing the work I brought from Japan.
This time I'm here for work, not for holidays, so
I'm not conscious of wanting to see my roots at the moment.
Each
person has his or her own way of shaving, um, it went well, so even if it went well for another person, that person wouldn't be able to shave well, so it went
well.
If there is a part where Mayu wants to be the center and wants to be in something, I
'm always thinking about what I want to write, um, every
day.
I don't think it's going to stop at the city where I'm going to go to where
I want to go, so I think I can tell you about that.
I think it's about thinking
Bragg blog Well, Facebook is the only one that's working to improve it in clumsy English,
so I thought it would be best to have people look at a separate page.
I'm doing twitter, but it's already in Japanese, so I think it's a
little
hard to read,
but I don't do twitter.
I
don't feel embarrassed when I'm called by 9 names because I think I'm the king because it's called ING, or a progressive finger.